it gets pretty hot I mean I don't really
mind it it's everything
up until I put the helmet on because a
helmet isn't really ventilated that well
all the lifts in here are actually three
inches but I want to eventually have
five to six inch lifts my Vader is six
six and a half the original Vader is
about six eight six nine these forms
like certain people like make certain
things like certain crops or whatever
one guy in the forms actually made this
for me because my Bader's from the
Empire Strikes Back
for the love of horses the only part I
actually made myself got a template and
just did it myself I wear about three
speakers I have breathing sometimes I do
I walk around with music and then I have
a voice changer
check-check testing it's you know just
kind of cool like you know becoming the
person or one of like the characters
that you always kind of like looked up
to that you grew up watching it's like a
little kid
the helmet a friend of mine was parting
ways with it and I just took it retooled
it sharpened a lot of the edges then I
went to auto shop and had everything
like repainted it specific color schemes
we're going to walk around the streets
of San Diego outside a comic-con with
this GoPro and see how many people I can
scare maybe for show let's do